مرحبا بعد اقل من شهر من بدا عرض فيلم
عياده الرياض في السينمات السعوديه
السريعا خرج الفيلم وسط الكثير من
الانتقادات اللي طالته واللي يشهد عوده
الفنان محمد العيسى بعد طول الغياب حيث
اتهم صناع الفيل ومشغلين السنوات بعدم دعم
الفيل على حساب افلام عربيه اخرى وانهم
المتسببين في سقوط الفيل على الشباك
جميل
المشاهده كوميدي خفيف في رساله حلوه
بنصحكم الصراحه تتابعون الفيلم قصه الفيلم
اخذت قالب استهلاكي تم تقديمه من ايام
الابيض والاسود القروي اللي ما قد طلع من
قريته ويروح للمدينه وتتغير حياته بشكل
كامل بشكل او باخر وهذا ما عندي معاه
مشكله خذ القالب اللي يناسبك والقصه اللي
تناسبك واسردها ولكن بشكل مختلف
بشكل جديد بشكل عصري بشكل يناسب الحقبه
الزمنيه اللي انت فيها
[موسيقى]
بعد نجاح الموسم الثالث من مسرحيه خطه
كيوبيد انطلقت عروض الموسم الرابع من
المسرحيه واللي لا زالت تعرض في قاعده
بمسرح السلام خطه كيوبي تناقش العلاقه ما
بين الرجل والمراه في اطار يجمع ما بين
التراجيديا والكوميديا كاميرا كواديس كانت
هناك وتوقفت مع نجوم وفريق العمل لمعرفه
بعض اسرار هذا النجاح
الفكره نفسها بتتكلم عن كيوبيت رمز الحب
اللي كلنا عارفينه بس احنا متناولينه من
وجهه نظر تاني لانه تمت الحب الاساسيه هي
الحب
فاحنا عاوزينه بشكل قوامري شويه انه ده
فرضيه انه ماذا لو كيوبيد خرج على المعاش
وبطل يشتغل
بس بيضطر يرجع تاني لانه بنته وابن اخوه
بيخشوا في ارتباط وخطوبه وكده فبيبدا يشوف
ما بينهم كل المشاكل اللي هو شافها قبل
كده في بصفته كيوبيد يعني وبيبدا يحطهم في
اختبارات انا بلعب دور سليم بنت كيوبيد
طبعا كلنا عارفين هو رمز الحب
بنشوفه بقى الراجل ده بعد ما طلع على
المعاش من شغله
بيبقى فاضي بقى لبنته وخطيبها ازاي بيحاول
ان هو طول الوقت بيوفق ما بينهم ازاي ان
هو بيحاول يعمل لهم خطه خطه دي
بتتغلب على فكره مخاوف كل واحد فيهم عن
طريق القيمه المعروفه اللي هي قيمه الحب
فكره العرض حلو قوي هي
بتلمس على موضوع
الجواز
وايه اللي بيحصل فيما بعد عشان يعرفهم ان
الموضوع مش حب واني فستان ابيض وبدله
وفرحه وبس لا ده في مسؤوليه وانتم داخلين
على حياه مش دي النهايه اللي انتم تتجوزوا
لا دي البدايه وبنشوف بقى كل ما هو يربط
العلاقه الانسانيه دي اللي هي تحت مسمى
الحب ما بين الشاب والبنت ما بين الزوج
وزوجته وبنشوف بقى ان الحب اساس كويس وحجر
كويس كبدايه ولكن مش هو كل حاجه انا لازم
نبقى عارفين عشان الحب ده يستمر ويدوم
ويفضل موجود انه في المسئوليه في فكره
الاهتمام في فكره المصارحه في فكره ان
احنا فعلا داخلين شركاء في الحياه دي
سهل جدا وبسيط جدا وقريب من كل الناس هو
الشاب المطحون اللي عايز يتجوز
ودائما في خناق مع خطيبته
بس ما يقدرش يستغنى عنها هو ده اللي احنا
لاعبين عليه في العرض ان انا اتخانق وازعل
واعمل كل حاجه بس ما اقدرش ان احنا نفركش
الموضوع ونقول يلا نسيب بعض
[موسيقى]
في زياره خاصه بابطال فيلم المطاريط حيث
يتم تخصيص عروض خاصه مع ابطال العمل محمود
الليثي احمد حاتم مصطفى غريب ومحمود حافظ
بعضهم تعتبر هذه هي الزياره الاولى لاهل
السعوديه بينما سبق وان شارك اخرون في
عروض خاصه او مسرحيات سابقه الفيلم يتم
امتداد لفيلم قديم للنجم يونس الشلبي
بعنوان اربعه اثنين اربعه وهو من تاليف
صلاح الجهيني واخراج ياسر سامي احنا
الفيلم ده حلقه خاصه احنا تعبنا فيه شويه
في تصويره لانه طبعا اغلبته مشطات كوره
فكنا بتنزل شهر سبعه وثمانيه ودرجات
الحراره عاليه جدا ومن تاني يوم عيد
الاضحى الكبير كنا بنصور يعني حتى ما
اخذناش اجازه في سبيل ان احنا ربنا قدرنا
ونعمل حاجه كويسه ان شاء الله صاحب نادي
ومدرب كوره بالغصب مجمع فرقه بالغصب
وبياخد لعيبه دول غصب عنه عشان ما تسمعوش
فلوس
فخصه بحبها جدا كاتبها صلاح الجهيني
[موسيقى]
والشاشه مصريه بهذا العنوان استقبلت
الصحافه النفسيه في ملهى مرحى عين واللي
بدا الاسبوع الماضي عرضه تجاريا في
السينمات المصريه حيث ينافس الفيلم افلام
مصريه اخرى ابرزها اخي فوق الشجره نبيله
الجميل انا لحبيبي المطاريد واثنين
للايجار تاتي هذه الخطوه بعد النجاح
الجماهير الكبير للفيلم في السعوديه حيث
لا زال ضمن قوائم الافلام الخمسه الاكثر
حضورا على الشباك السعودي كان فيها كثير
من صعوبه خصوصا انت بتتكلم عن حقبه قبل
عشرين سنه فتفاصيلها كثير شخصيات كثيره في
الفيلم
الانتاج كبير طبعا فيلم كوميدي حاجه جميله
جدا امكانيات اللي انت تشوف فيلم سعودي في
السينما المصريه دي اول مره تحقق السنه دي
فدي حاجه طبعا انبساط